hold the pickles gang little tour update
Vermont in Connecticut we added second
shows of both of those cities come out
and see the boys yeah get the tickets
before they're sold out we got uh
Connecticut Vermont and then we're going
down to Florida baby Tampa second show
added limited tickets left on that then
we're in Dania Beach Florida we're going
to Raleigh North Carolina Louisville
Kentucky Cleveland Ohio Columbus Ohio
more cities coming soon get those
Dickies gang let's party welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's a little
show we sit there with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy yeah it's just a big old piece
of trash I'm your host Dave souley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at Toody's in a new New
Edition baby living high on the hog if
you're stopping by use the side door you
don't want you traping mud to the front
I'll tell you that right now she's out
there spending that cut my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he
is the CEO of Ru garbage he is an
international businessman and my best
pal in a whole wide world and I love him
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
everybody hey what's up gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate of you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
the [__] out gang it's a party over
there yes it is and how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones works the
twos crosses the t's and dots the eyes
now you can get a little peek at him
ladies give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
Toby McMullen everybody what up dudes
what's up bro bro cut the fingers off
your gloves get the chain wallets out we
got one of the gnarliest dudes in comedy
I love this guy got a [__] real one
here ladies and gentlemen gang we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time you've all wanted him and he's
finally here he is a legendary stand-up
comedian actor and podcaster you may
have seen him in but not limited to
check this out we got Ugly Americans we
have an unbelievable episode of Louie we
have Inside Amy Schumer we have billions
we have the Jim Gaffigan show we have
crashing isn't it romantic Hustlers the
cabin Comic View bad boys of Comedy
white boys in the hood Comedy Central
presents The Green Room Jimmy Fallon
kill Tony WTF Comedy Underground this is
not happening at midnight comedy
knockout we got the Comedy Jam we got
Conan we got what's your effing deal 14
episodes of that no big deal we got Joe
Rogan the degenerates this week at the
Comedy Cellar something's burning he has
an amazing special live at Webster Hall
you can hear him every week on the
bonfire on Sirius XM and he is the host
of legion of skanks and he has a brand
new special out right now that you got
check out on his YouTube page called dog
belly ladies and gentlemen he needs no
introduction but we gave him on anyway
because we love him give it up for Big
Jay oakerson let's go
let's [__] gone hey Jay baby I'm so
excited this is finally working out I
really feel like and I'm in the new
studio which is beautiful thank you by
the way and I I don't know if it's
organically and so we're cut from the
same clothes yeah the same way and uh my
first thought when I sat down table I'd
go oh nice they put the Leafs in exactly
all the same cookie different shapes yet
you still had a favorite yeah
like everybody's coming over you want
the pretzel one I love the pretzel come
on it tastes just like the other one
it's got the sugar on it though shout
out to them I remember when I finally
started to appreciate them was sometime
in high school and I was stoned and just
knocked through a tin of those things oh
you're like sugar while boring it's
sugar you don't get milk it'll hit that
same spot it ain't bad man it ain't bad
it'll get the job buddy congratulations
on the new special oh thank you you said
you had trouble getting here what
happened fill us in on that before we
get to the backstory uh well one it's
raining outside so uh getting an Uber
was a pain in the ass and then when I
got the Uber it was just crazy I guess
because the weather yeah it's bad
traffic and then uh when I was about
five blocks away
I was already like 17 minutes late at
that point and I was supposed to be and
I even said I'd be there in 20 minutes
late so I'm like I go sir I gotta get
out and then I got a podcast and then I
I like you know fast walked
uh five blocks like uh I said with the
emotion of like I'm trying to stop a
girl I love that I never told I love her
from getting on that let's get that job
in Italy she's getting ready to get on
the plane wait darling where's gate 64.
hey man you can't park there I'll leave
the car not in front of the airport keep
it
you feel like you say keep it
unfortunately now is when you try to and
you try to run through a TSA preacher
and you get clubbed down by eight guys
you get tased [__] German Shepherd he
goes not only this guy trying to jump
security he's also got five ounces of
Listerine in his pocket
where you going with that shampoo
but no you don't understand there's a
girl I love
he goes would you mind raising your arms
in this thing please all right sir I
gotta check if you have a mental ass for
some reason there's a yellow Square over
your ass
dude as we as we said and we were saying
before we want to have you on for so
long everybody's been asking for it and
it just seems like you know like fate oh
it's in the new studio yeah it's great I
can't thank you enough for being here
congratulations on everything we [__]
love you today thank you for having me
uh we're gonna take this one nice and
slow give us the start with the back
story
hit us Jersey South Jersey South Jersey
well we'll start in West Philly ah right
right
um so start from the beginning uh mom
dad had me when they were 19.
garbage that's not classy
[Laughter]
uh that's that split when I was three or
I think it was asked to leave
uh and then he makes a difference he was
like okay and then he went to Florida
uh were they married did they get
married yeah okay
um I don't remember the divorce being
messy necessarily I think it was just
kind of a quick thing but uh he went to
Florida I think in a few months after
that came back
married that I now understand is an
older lady
at the time well you know my dad was old
to me but he was probably
23 or four yeah and uh my first
stepmother was like 40. already and a
mother of like
twin teenage boys and a redhead teenage
boy which is hilarious no one's redhead
in that family yeah
um and then I mentioned this on
something the other day that always
struck me as weird my dad
has not spent enough time with me or
doesn't know me well enough to have ever
really hit me
I think he gave me like a very soft face
like push almost once but that's it dude
he used to like give her kids like the
spoon
and you have to hear him go upstairs and
hear like that sound like the like the
the t a thousand S's and a t like
because they were just Joe Jackson
zipped by my dad in the air it was so
bizarre 13 year old twin boys getting
spanked on the ass with a spoon by my
dad not there
a guy that's 10 years older than them
yeah
and he's also 10 years old that's just
like a fair fight at that point you
asked me for money yesterday this is
[__] they're real dad by the way it
was like a Texas like
cowboy hat guy it was so weird and then
uh and then just to give that side of
the story of the dad and then he when I
was
uh well actually I'll say that my mom I
was with my mom my grandparents had me a
lot of the time in West Philly yeah this
was still in West Philly it's just you
and your mom me and my mom and my but my
grandparents were like super involved
right they lived a couple blocks away
always
they would take me when my mom you know
my mom is at work what's that side of
the family Italian Irish what are those
the Jewish they're Jewish yeah that's
all the Jewish okay
practicing no okay no no my mom couldn't
wait to get like Christmas [__] into
our household really yeah my dad's not
Jewish my stepfather is the furthest
thing from Jewish
he's uh but so was my grandparents and
my grandfather died when I was 10
um and but like even then most of the
time even my step pop first came around
my mom started dating my step pop
when uh that's a fun story of the night
they met great one actually lay it on us
my mom met my step pop at uh okay I love
you guys are from Philly too they met at
Carney's that used to be uh it's right
in Bala Cynwyd I think now it's a like
an urgent care center the place but it
was right across from like you know like
Channel 10 is and yeah around that
corner there the old Adams Mark Hotel
yeah the New York Life building is over
there too it's right it's right there it
was a place called Corners nightclub and
my mom
brought my step up home that night I was
my grandmother's
back to West Philly I almost feel yeah I
was at my grandmother's and my mom a
couple blocks away at our place brought
my to be stepfather home for the night
to [__]
I don't think they were gonna play
Parcheesi for sure wasn't the look at
your trophies so my mom my mom used to
uh
she like dated over time like and data's
a loose word like she hooked up with a
couple cops
uh single mom she was busy you're young
too you gotta think early 20s probably
right she wasn't getting gangbang like
that chinless [__] from that one police
station
I think she gets a bad rap too by the
way me too yeah they should have come
down here who cares nothing wrong with
that
dude you know I all have one of those
cops wives got word of it and was just
like we're exposing sure she she made
you do that because she's a [__]
um so my mom would like uh I thought
they were just friends I almost thought
it was kind of cool that a guy was
coming with a gun belt to our house and
[__] and then it was like hey hit the
sack
so I'll give you a shot of NyQuil and
again she'll say they were just friends
sure let's say it's fine it's true but
one of them what they did was Dave very
blonde guy
tall always they had the mustaches his
thing was he would Shine the Light into
our the top we were on the top floor of
a duplex apartment he'd shine into our
window and that was the sign that uh I'm
coming over it's like when the doorbell
rings or whatever it's me gotcha so you
know come over here they just be on
shift and they would come over literally
and like I don't know if I was awake
nothing but who knows Christ knows what
happened in the middle of the night but
he would shine that light
and that means he's coming
um
and then uh so he did that that night
and my mom had my step pop up there so
she just uh what's funny was when the
doorbell rang she was ignoring it
because it was like wow I'm just act
like I'm asleep or I'm not here whatever
it is doesn't matter go it's like not
like a big deal
um cops don't go away yeah no he did go
not only that
he never rang the doorbell
he did that apparently and got a call or
something and couldn't come up and this
isn't cell phones we could let her know
he just like uh he just took off
the doorbell still rang because my mom
went on a date with the guy
that she my mom was funny too for being
Jewish even like her Jewish friend
that's why I never understood until I
moved to New York
when I moved to New York first time I
saw Jews where I went oh
like that's what they mean sure my mom
like friends were like backyard like
biker parties type thing you know I mean
that's what it was more that it was more
that you know I mean like uh
like weird like like Philly people that
were into country sure that weird that
subculture yeah
and she met a guy at one of those
barbecues named Ron it's always Iran oh
yeah Ron or Randy floating around a date
with Ron I don't think it worked out she
wasn't that any or whatever
but Ron apparently was an alcoholic and
aft by chance after that guy flashed the
window Ron just decided to show up and
start ringing the doorbell at two in the
morning or whatever
so he's ringing the doorbell but he's
not stopping ringing and they're almost
like that's kind of weird like my mom
says like it's a friend of mine who was
going to come over the cop she's like
he's but I'll just ignore it
uh then they hear a smack a window smash
and the guy punched through one of the
little you know square square windows
open the thing came upstairs my step hop
is hilarious so funny he's uh
genius he's an academic and also a power
lifter and more personality of that than
like a guy who's book smart sure
and uh thank God he was like cool
anything because he didn't beat the [__]
out of the guy they literally like
wrapped up his wounds and took care of
called an ambulance and so
I hope she at least sucked them all for
something else like something because he
deserves it and it's just this is always
so funny this is the first meeting of my
stepfather my long time step up who I
love he's my family you know I mean like
uh there's nothing you know he might as
well be a father to me for sure but our
first meeting was me and my friend John
stayed at my Grandmom's the night before
came home the next day and the first
thing we see Windows smashed out and
then I mean a soupy trail of blood going
up you know whatever three flights of
steps
and then uh and then I opened my front
door which is obviously weirdly kind of
open but not my mom's not there it's my
step up wearing a a button-down shirt
with like a wife beater underneath so
you can see he's like you know muscular
and stuff
ripping a Newport sitting in his pleated
jeans on my couch and he goes hey
first 48. I've been waiting on you kiddo
you're the last one I got again so no
Witnesses go get your grandparents will
you yeah just look this is the face
you're gonna want revenge on in 20 years
that was my first uh hey big guy how you
doing yeah it goes hey champ
what do you think of the Eagles this
year
who's that comfortable in a crime scene
just a [__] hang out and rip eaters
oh [__] so God damn that's my first
meeting with him so my step pup comes in
to the picture when I was like 11 10 or
11. they get married
well come on dude what's the show called
she got pregnant I had a child okay when
the child was like two they got married
maybe even like one are you at this
wedding and involved in this one I could
be was in Susan's backyard
it was next door it'd be weird if I
wasn't
if you're looking at your bedroom window
I was bringing the Ziti of course was I
there
[__]
she was in his backyard
Susan's backyard
season her face yeah
as far as I know Superman
hey we got a problem you could have said
something
[Laughter]
uh
so yeah my brother was born they got
married and then
for the next uh I guess what was it
eight years
yeah for the next like eight years it
was uh
every four she'd have another kid since
my two sisters Okay so
and I'm 11 years older than my brother
15 and my sister and 19 then my other
sister and I was just kind of In-House I
have 10 and 16. yeah so what's your
youngest sibling step sibling she's uh
half siblings but uh they're uh she's 25
25. did you guys stay in that house 20
26 by now
um so because you moved to every Dirtbag
who gets a couple of bucks crosses the
Bridge moves to South Jersey what did he
do grandfather pass away when I was
almost 10
and he was big that was a big one for me
and then it was just so funny as though
even with my step pop being around
this is what I always find so funny my
step thought was right he's a guy
he was a great male influence in so many
ways he brought uh dirty comedy in my
life he brought uh you know like the
guys talking [__] kind of element of it
and stuff but he's still it was so funny
that he stole it and bring like
masculinity in the sense of like
I still if you were like hey change
these breaks I'm like if you gave me all
the equipment I couldn't change I don't
know what I'm doing yeah are you kidding
me a spark plug where it goes I remember
my dad when I was young I go to see him
he would always be so disappointed he's
like we're going on AutoZone I'm getting
these I remember explaining me split
fire
uh spark plugs he was like you see
because it's the split fire so it's got
two Sparks so it burns the gas more if I
make I don't know whatever try to do
this now bro yeah I'm here for the
weekend
really trying to cram a lot in today
have you seen Gallagher's new special
relate to me yeah know what I like you
weirdo what did Ron do what does your
stepdad do they patched him up and uh no
no what what did he's back oh Joe Joe
Joe I'm sorry what does he do for a
living so when he met my mom
while he's a super smart guy he was
essentially uh like a Coke guy not then
he went to the Navy to get off Coke he
was probably like a year removed from
the Navy
um was he Italian I pictured yeah I
picture like a [__] oh yeah yeah
Italian and he's uh
and he was uh he worked at GNC and like
worked out like competing like
powerlifting contest working at a GNC in
Philly he worked in the GNC Granite Run
Mall oh we have to go pick him up
because he also didn't have a car
but I was like uh but also like you got
a minute your mom's young right yeah
yeah she's 29. yeah it's like that's not
that crazy no I'm trying to get it
together she was well what most of my
young like my mom just worked in retail
and then one of them I don't know why
this didn't dawn on me most of my life
until now
is there where did you work in retail
like uh whatever so I was like no it's
funny like she did know her thing we
were broke and she had a fat kid and my
mom became like At first she would when
I was a little little kid she worked the
smallest Formal Wear renting tuxedos
okay and then I would be the little
model at the fashion shows they had to
go to
which I do have pictures of I'll be
happy to send you guys though
as you see this tuxedo pairs well with a
chain wallet
and then when she saw it was going to be
a a husky child uh she became like a
manager at Casual Male big and tall no
way yeah so then I'm gonna have to close
this animal
I can't be buying husky clothes on my my
salary oh so it's whatever it was op a
lot of Ocean Pacific shout outs I was a
big op Kid myself buddy so they um
and my mom so when my grandfather passed
away
she kind of like promised that she was
gonna do like more so she went back to
because she went to Philadelphia
Community College associates for
respiratory therapy okay which pretty CR
if I didn't do before I figured out I
wanted to try to do comedy I was
literally just going to do that because
this is my thought of respiratory
therapy it's a noble job it's a great
it's very important job sure it's a
major important job in emergency rooms
and hospitals and everything and it
makes good money and you only got to go
to school for two years so my mom was
just kind of finishing that up when she
met my stepfather
and then she got pregnant and they're
gonna have the kid they're gonna get
married and my step pop just kind of had
like a he's so smart he was like oh man
I gotta figure something out he goes hey
Terry what do you do again there's like
respiratory therapy he goes yeah I guess
I'll just do that he just went to
Philadelphia Community College and just
aced it he like finished early and they
like Roxboro Hospital said they'll pay
for his second year if he like promises
to work there for a couple years I think
he still works yeah he's still at
Roxboro hospital he's a good head of
whatever there but like uh and still
also then he comes home and like
throws chains on the end of like a
barbell that's got a bunch of weight on
it it's just so funny is he still in
good shape uh I mean for his AJ he's
like in his 60s now yeah he's like
strong as [__] for sure and when did you
guys move out to one of them Jersey uh
when my step pop uh probably about two
years after they were both working
steadily uh as respiratory therapists it
was like yeah well our first upgrade was
we moved across the street into a row
home instead of uh top of the duplex
gotcha same block a few houses down
which I thought I was like this is wow
we got cable yeah it was nuts you look
at the old house like yeah they're bad
garbage living in an apartment this
episode is brought to you by better help
okay we got a couple of screws loose
over there yeah buddy I know we all do I
need a screwdriver get in here tighten
them up online therapy that's the way to
go you're doing the Comfort you're at
home you get to talk to a licensed
therapist and you know they might not
have the specialist you're looking for
in your home down better help
can help yeah uh guy you know I I'm
gonna be you get stuck in your head
you're spinning your wheels you're
trying to figure it out you need you
need to you need to get that stuff out
and have someone else go whoa stop
thinking that do this do that figure it
out it's fantastic I'm a big proponent
of uh talk therapy it's been uh crucial
in my life at several different points
uh a time except when my mom made me go
when my parents got divorced I'll never
forgive you for that take a quick survey
to get connected with a licensed
therapist I better help uh it's
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule if you need to switch
therapists make make the change at no
additional charge discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com garbage today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash garbage one more time
gang take control of your life that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com garbage do it Kevin here's a
home run baby let's talk about that
liquid IV liquid eye vessel let me give
you a couple of ways you can use Liquid
IV you got like 103 Screaming fever can
snort it I was sucking that down left
and right got me through the flu or the
stomach virus whenever I had a few weeks
back
um you go to the gym you sure Powers you
through your workout and let's say after
the gym you meet up with a couple of
your friends you have two tree Pops that
turns into 40 50 uh Long Island Iced
Teas you wake up the next morning you
feel like crap sure liquid IV hydrate
you hydrate you quicker and the flavors
are fantastic and here's the turkey 45
calories yeah it's got five essential
vitamins and like the big man said it's
two times the hydration of water alone
just mix one stick uh with water and
you're good to go I thought in a little
plastic water bottle shake it up but
they did send us nice canteens at the
same time to birds
uh you got 12 incredible flavors like
Seaberry strawberry lemonade concord
grape pina colada it's a delicious way
to mix up your hydration routine uh has
three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drink is gluten-free
dairy free and soy free right now you
grab your liquid IV in bulk Nationwide
over over there Costco sure or you can
get 20 off when you go to liquid iv.com
use code garbage at checkout that's 20
off anything you order when you shop
better hydration today using promo code
garbage at liquid iv.com do it so we uh
and then we move to the townhouse too I
guess but in uh South Jersey when I was
16. so 16 years old my uh where are we
going to school when you were in West
Philly Lamberton it was that have been
your high school where it was
kindergarten through 12th grade really
the smart kids would go off to
Mastermind or Central okay yeah my
cousin went to sleep they would go off
for that or like uh Gratz I think was
another kind of one you can get out of
but for the most part you went to Saint
callistus if you were catholic
uh went to Catholic school or you went
to Lambert and Lamberton was just
kindergarten through 12th grade ninth
grade they doing a synagogue across the
street because no one cares about the
synagogue yeah
um yeah we were talking about this in
skanks the other day too I've never
experienced in school for all the
garbage things I did experience I'm
still Blown Away by how many people my
age younger older who are like yeah
every kind of neighborhood had like
teacher [__] kid uh student or a guy or
girl [__] friends Dad or Mom like a an
adult [__] like a a teenager story I
never nothing my school that school from
kindergarten through 12th grade was the
oldest of old white ladies
very strong personality older black
women
very foreigny like Indian ladies and so
I was like maybe the guy teachers were
getting some love from the girls
students but I don't I didn't have age I
didn't have a teacher
through 12 years of schooling that was
attractive ever really now that said
my first album I did at stand up New
York
an American Storyteller it's fun because
in the audience is my daughter at the
time
[Music]
her current kindergarten teacher who is
smoking hot and I think I get her
talking about taking it in the [__]
on the show I think I keep saying I go
it's my daughter's kindergarten
she's currently my daughter's gender she
has to call us in and be like she's not
doing well with letters or whatever and
I'm going to be like well how do you
know
you're gonna make your word for it well
you're over here trying you're trying
all your silent farts coming out because
your [__] walls don't touch anymore
you pig
okay all right so you move it you move
out to South Jersey where'd you go to
high school out there
Triton High School was called Triton
height is it you is this near Voorhees
it's Runnymede so yeah yeah okay I mean
it's like a town before Voorhees I
remember driving by and seeing run him
it just sounds trashy to me run a mead
oh yeah yeah it is trashy pawn shops uh
but a great Diner Jersey has some great
diners tucked away in there I feel like
all of them now I think an unspoken
victim of the pandemic is the diner of
100 almost none of them are open 24
hours yeah it's brutal especially in New
York forget about it like shitty
restaurants yeah yeah faselka one of the
classic 24 hours places 10 o'clock yeah
it's crazy uh what was the mascot the
high school mascot for in Philly it was
uh the Blue Devils okay respectable
no uh out of school competitive teams
though so
maybe maybe in uh cross country
no basketball team nothing intramural
bowling because the center because the
center bowling lanes were uh maybe like
a seven minute walk from school
you get one year I forget what year was
maybe 10th or 11th grade or something
probably 10th grade your uh gym class
for a session of it for like a semester
of it was everybody walked over the
bowling night but the good thing was
they didn't really govern your boat you
had the bowl but you also can go over
and get some Otis Spunkmeyer cookies
shout out to it shout out to a bowling
alley [__] uh concession stand yeah
they weren't all bad it wasn't it wasn't
that's great it wasn't some dirty water
dog thing had snap
I don't know who's working
[Laughter]
full-on arcade that's actually the
bowling I love having other details that
going backwards that bowling alley is
where my uh mother and father also met
because my dad was a pin Setter and my
mom was there hanging out and then he
had just hanging out of the hanging out
at a bowling alley is a tough look she's
hanging out of the following hour at 19
and my dad's setting the pins he's a
human machine
hey when I get this [__] alley wax
off my hands can I cream pie you
[Laughter]
what was high school like so you got
over there at South Jersey you said 16.
yeah so you're like a sophomore junior
uh junior yeah and what was uh how were
the grades
never I always just did enough to kind
of get by it
no I took the PSATs I don't think I did
great
but I think I genuinely did a pattern
because it was like they said on that
PSAT day like when you're done
you're done it was a school day and I
was just like
yeah
yeah I did the same thing with the essay
yeah I genuinely I didn't I knew I
didn't give a [__] about school I was
always going to do as much school as I
had to do which is an interesting thing
having a 20 year old daughter now whose
mother is an academic
and then me you know like my daughter
was like I don't know she went like a
semester of like especially doing it at
home and everything
but she also didn't want to go away to
college either you know and it's so
funny me getting that more I'm like yeah
we'll just go like you know do whatever
just do something yeah do something I
don't care what it is yeah but I don't
give a [__] if you go to college or not
you also have my favorite unless you
want to go to college she's like hey I
want to be a nurse that's awesome news
she's just like I don't know but they're
telling me just take a math class and
like don't waste my money like that
I'll be talking and rolling and [__]
just doing rolling she's gonna go to
esthetician school I'm like there's the
oakerson right there let's get it done
and the name lives on
is you dressing like Peggy Bundy
and The Legend Continues
you didn't get your blackheads
she does it like no one else
he did one open mic and then didn't you
like drop out of college you were in
yeah he did one open mic a black comedy
club open mine he's like I'm gonna be
famous tomorrow or whatever it just it
was so unenrolled from college
unenrolled yeah withdrew from the four
classes it was yeah it was so funny and
I did that the first time I did it I
think you know I bet if there was a tape
of it it went at very best okay sure uh
it was definitely a Jerry Springer joke
in there and I was like how can nobody
in comedy be talking about Jerry Smith
it was already hacky uh but I didn't
know you know I mean but I went but
whatever it was just when I did it in my
mind I guess because it didn't go bad I
was like I just did stand up comedy was
where I go well this is the thing
goodbye rudimentary math class going all
in on this I also did College in such a
shitty way like I didn't want to be
there so I would hear all those things
like oh you could take you know three
day a week biology class because or you
could pop in there for four hours on a
Saturday and I was like well but then
it's over and then just like on that
Saturday it's like why would I the [__]
am I doing it for four hours or leave in
the middle of it when there's like a you
know a little break they give you I'm
like
guys I used to come home like it was
high school I used to come over to my
mom and be like there was no parking
there
not a whole spot
a whole Township I could have fine I go
there's some Park people parking The
Lawns but I don't know if you're allowed
to do that so she's like you have to go
you're paying for college I go what are
we doing a park
pencil broke what do you want from here
sharpeners
this is college they expect to be adults
with our own sharp pencils some people
walking in there like an [__] they
don't live in the townhouse still do
they yeah they still live there yeah you
still down in South Jersey it's so funny
the only thing I remember
liking about college at all was that was
the time I have a a bit I've done about
it forever now because it's just a funny
story of going uh
what was it called the fantasy show bar
on Black Horse Pike when you were 18.
but uh when we used to go there when we
were 18 as soon as you I think we even
got in a couple times it was no booze no
booze but it was all nude full name they
do they used to do shows and dude we
were like 18-2 went over there and these
two girls started going at it on stage
in like the shower room or whatever they
hate us wild for that reason again I
don't you know as you become an adult
you understand tipping and doing the
right thing and even if you go to a
strip club because you're like wow I'm
not really a new one but like yeah the
three of us are in whatever like it's
across the street let's walk into this
place
you're gonna drop a uh you know if if
you've got to throw a couple of them you
gotta throw a couple bucks you gotta
skip them for their services yeah you do
the right thing yeah
our thing was like how can we get away
when the
internet first came out
and uh you know the printer paper was uh
there was a thing for fancy show bar
where it's like you know like a school
reports oh there's no pictures and the
pictures were always made with like
you know uh clipart or whatever no not
even the pictures were like that's a
tits but like made from like dashes and
sure right parentheses like binary code
or whatever yeah yeah yeah
and the fancy show Bars thing had a girl
on the cover who was like there the girl
like the professional one that worked
there we used to go on amateur night but
you'd still see the pro girls I respect
the art you know what I mean I don't
want to see the Razzle Dazzle and me and
my friends would print they had a a deal
that was
them not knowing how good of it they
were giving too much away but if they
didn't know they were giving it to
children who had no money
we needed for a night at this place
couple hours we needed three bucks Jesus
because this pass you'd point out was
free
um entry okay which was already probably
like 10 bucks or something right
um a free
it was two things oh the well now the
drinks were free the sodas were free you
still gotta tip a dollar for it oh oh
yeah so so when you walk in so the
entrance was free when you walk in
there's a girl if you remember the Beast
just standing there yeah the first thing
they called the titty hug so when you're
going first things first you got to put
a dollar in your mouth and the girl's
gonna pull a daughter which is known in
my circles okay okay well you know it's
a vernacular changes places you can put
it together ah titty sandwich
Jay's got a check in his mouth
I have to move some things around
says the gas company on it
that's how I move so you'd have to give
her a dollar then a lady walks you guys
to your seats and then she just flat out
puts a a garter belted leg up on the
thing and you got to put the dollar in
there now you're two in yeah and then at
some point you wait because here's what
I also got you that was brilliant again
us not realizing anything about
marketing or anything we bound to it
what they would give you for free and
not even ask for tips is non-stop of the
most delicious butteriest saltiest
popcorn you could possibly have I don't
remember the popcorn it was so but all
that did was make you have to so we
would just get like like yeah like mouth
suck dry and then be like I'll have a
Sprite now please there's your other
dollar
what that free pass gave us was free
entry and free uh shower Show entrance
when you're talking about shower show
that show something else I've been to
again I haven't been to actually a ton
of strip clubs I still think about that
every once in a while but it is I've
never seen a Broadway show
I imagine I mean
Pizzazz is that a cop possible word how
good could Miss Saigon be
no that show of the strip clubs I've
been in and stuff
unreal that show was on
was it faked probably didn't matter it
was like I was like watching a porn it
was like a 15 almost 20 minute thing and
they the people who bought it was 25 to
go in there
and then uh it's like these kind of like
just like lines of like bleachers and
then a shower stall yeah and they would
take turns one would sit behind well
first things first they go
uh five dollars to come up and be a soap
person and then because we had no money
we'd always our thing to ourselves be
like dude what a loser what kind of nerd
yeah you [__] pain
right here buddy I would have given
fifty dollars if it was in my pocket
dude I did it the first time I got a
massage uh prostitute I gave her 100 of
the money in my pocket because she told
me it was 300 and I was like I don't
have that and she goes what do you have
and I went 200 and she goes okay and I
just gave her it was 100 of the money in
my pocket listen you're a nice boy I'll
do it for two hundred yeah you would
have done it for 50 if I probably would
have said so if I just saw it all over
me I'm like no way
because you do have even now as you know
you do have like childish wonderment
sometimes you're like very like oh yeah
yes and uh and so uh the shower show
we'd sit in the back so everyone do
their five hours and they'd soap the
girls tits up
and uh and then we just sit there and
then they would take turns sitting
behind one another
and for like probably five minutes each
at least like they would uh one would
hold the shower spray on the other one's
[__] and the other one would just and
she would just play with her own [__]
and fake like they would do it it was
never just like now switch they would
fake come or come Academy award-winning
performances it was a lot like they went
for if it makes sense it'd probably be
less embarrassing to just come than to
fake what they were doing sure yeah sure
that makes sense you almost be it's like
I'm gonna make a wacky noise I might as
well make it actually happen but
probably not the case then they would
switch spots and the other one would
start over and do it all over again
buddy they actually started asking us to
start like ripping off the
you know the the trash
can you at least please like they hated
us
um I never realized it at all but their
main girl that was on the website like
the only real picture on the website and
you could just see just the long blonde
hair just the quintessential stripper
chicks big tits whatever
um what I loved the only thing I
remember today the only day I remember
at Camden County Community College
was uh going she wasn't even any of my
classes I was walking out and just
seeing her with like school books and
whatever the thing and I was like no way
it's like I mean it's probably not
Diamond but that's Diamond whatever her
name was and uh and then just watching
the slow like reality of like for some
reason I guess you just lived in my area
or something then uh like a couple weeks
later I saw her like working cashier at
like ShopRite also with like pictures of
like her kids but the you know I mean
like her kids and just like all the
reality of this thing is like oh she's
not a beautiful but like very early I
got that shot I go yeah she's just
struggling if her [__] was making that
much money she probably wouldn't be bad
yeah [__] cabbage at ShopRite yeah
you're rolling in there giving her
counterfeit money maybe if there's a
couple Big Spenders coming in from time
to time she wouldn't have to Moonlight
soap somebody up scumbag I never really
Affiliated my I am a part of that she's
like you I am part of the latter of that
woman's terrible life yes
okay let's talk about that manscape baby
listen spring cleaning don't stop in the
front in the backyard do yourself a
favor get them nuts cleaned up yeah
clean your Easter eggs before the
squirrels and the Gophers in the
neighborhood dogs start sniffing around
down there get yourself cleaned up gang
and you can do that with the performance
package
4.0 we're talking about the lawnmower
4.0 trimmer we're talking about the weed
whacker 2.0 sure talking about the ear
nose trimmer the crop preserver ball
deodorant let's go crop reviver toner
uh-huh performance boxer briefs and a
nice travel bag what are you doing I got
the travel bag I use it all the time
taking everyone a rude with me yeah guys
it's fantastic uh it's a game changer
take care you know if you got a him or
her in your life yeah make it easier on
the other view freshen it up what are we
doing you guys notice at this point uh
they teamed up with this also manscape
just teamed up with the testicular
cancer society for testing we're just
talking about awareness month to bring
awareness to Men's Health an early
cancer detection is part of we save
balls initiative uh testicular cancer is
the most common form of cancer in men in
ages 15 to 35 one man every hour is
every day is diagnosed take care of your
balls with manscape be sure to check out
cancer check for cancer at least once a
month right now you can save 20 off and
free shipping with code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code garbage at
manscape.com hop into the best deal of
the year with manscape baby now back to
the show oh man it's so funny but I also
loved having buddies in those strip
clubs who would um
like I really I was pretty early again
like my own insecurity has probably
saved me from like looking silly
sometimes because like when I hear in my
ear it's like it's like I'm so happy
there's finally like a normal guy in
here like you're cute
and I just had the thing I go well
that's clearly something she's paid to
say to try to get me to go to the thing
and then the best thing would just and
always to me it was always like
confident guys in the group they've
never coming to go yeah I'm gonna run
the back with her like she said she's
like digging me and stuff no she don't
normally do it but she's gonna do it
with me
I loved it I kind of loved the hustle of
it I'm like good for you lady I'm like
good for you like look at you go I
respect that yeah this chick likes me
man every single time somebody does not
not normally but I will for you you seem
like a real cool guy when I used to I
got a job these other losers in here
when I first started comedy at like 19 I
started working a job
my friend told me about this job being a
job that exists at all and I was like I
would do that and it was the driving
strippers and escorts to Bachelor
parties yeah that was always something I
wanted to do and uh it's it's it really
is not glamorous like you'd hope but so
funny the difference mine said I'd never
in my life would I ever think that's
glamorous that sounds like the saddest
[__] to me and you two guys are like you
did it you may have the same thing
though in my mind I was like well
they're stupid and now I'm not just a
guy in the audience I'm with them like I
know them not to work together but I'm
like I'm the guy so now I'm in a
position where it's like
clearly they do this and they get all
horned up and they're probably going to
want to just throw [__] at me
afterwards you find out very quickly
that like they want to go home and like
burn their epidermis off yeah like they
it's gross what they have what do they
see my 86 Toyota
but the first girl I ever drove every
time I'm getting wrapped up in someone's
like
pretty she was I thought she was
gorgeous I would love to see a picture
of her I mean you could barely see the
c-section scar on this chick definitely
had a kid
but you couldn't see no she was just
young Dr Young and just like she was
just young and hot she just had a thing
there's tan
gorgeous
and uh I took it and I said I was so
enamored it's funny when you watch
somebody doing like a piggish thing and
then but I was like I was like proud of
her because she did a thing I remember
what it was my first time ever doing it
so I'm like what is she gonna can't even
see the ping pong ball can you guys
similar thing actually she goes all
right guys get out your fives your tens
and your twenties
uh for fun you know round about when she
was telling you that she's gonna roll it
up into like you know a Coke straw
essentially thing and put it in her
[__] a little bit
if it's a five a little bit
and um you'll bite it out you take it
out of your teeth
ten dollars she's gonna put in a little
bit further and twenty dollars she's
gonna put it all the way in
here's the thing I don't know if it's
the best example to use as she's putting
this thing
in her [__] more or less
she's going this to hold it in
so a five dollar bill in her [__] is
only gonna be this long you could always
get as close as her fingers right
from what if you did a five dollar but
it was never going to change anything
sure every guy throws down to 20 because
they believe they're getting closer and
I was just there I'm like
brilliant
and beautiful I literally I was like I
was like this is wow look at her go I
got some amazing thing and then
afterwards we uh
we drove we stopped to the 7-Eleven and
I remember her getting like you know
whatever those junk ass roses or flowers
they have there are little bouquets
they'll have and she put them on the
thing and she bought them
and then we got in the car I'm like who
are the flowers for
I'm driving and by the way I'd already
gotten like to just trying to get my kid
back put my abusive ex-boyfriend
something something
and uh and I was like uh what are the
who are the flowers for and she goes for
me she goes after like a night of that
like I feel like I should have you know
I deserve flowers and I was like oh yeah
and I dropped her off and the next day
I drove to her house and knocked on her
door and I was like I think somebody
should buy you flowers and I was like
this is us falling in love
nope nothing at all and then cut ahead
two years take it off my property so
would you mind leaving you slide your
rolled up 20 back
okay fair enough
no she was like sweet but it was just
like it didn't like we didn't fall into
each other's arms the way I believe we
were going to and uh it was a weird move
for sure but she uh
you know I I worked with her maybe a
couple more times and she was like one
of the girls when you were like oh she's
like I'll make some money tonight too
because they tip you out afterwards so
I'll make somebody she like kills it
this girl's great as far as like doing
the job maybe like two years later or
something I was just like
having a raw you know I wasn't like
working too much in New York on the
weekends or Philly so I had like plenty
of weekends off
and I need to make money because I
wasn't making money in comedy so I was
like uh let me pick this job up again
that was a job I don't know what it's
like now
you can go in the phone book and find
like you know
Go-Go's entertainment or whatever and
call them and be like hey you need
drivers and I mean
more than once they're like yeah come by
now and uh we'll say yeah or whatever
yeah like yeah you're working the job
already you have a license okay can you
fight
they didn't even give a [__] about that
in fact when I asked her the job's
actually kind of dangerous at times
at least like in on the threat like
you're in a dangerous situation
um and the guy was like yeah don't you
carry a gun because I was like why do
all these old men do it like all these
old all these old like Italian guys do
it yeah they can't fight they can't and
I was like what's the thing and they go
yeah and he was almost like the point
he's like
and who's gonna you can't fight 25 guys
anyways like they have a gun I love her
man
get your hands over I had a guy
brandished a gun one time and all I
thought right away was the thing I go I
don't care if he shoots this girl 15
times in the face why am I gonna get
killed for protecting this lady I don't
know
um that's where I was like I am not the
right person to do this job
but um a couple years uh
I hadn't done it much at all and I
called this company he's like yeah come
over and I'll send you out I go to his
place was great and it was in a
apartment so some of the garbage like
are you garbage South Jersey
particularly I can't speak for anybody
else in the world
I've never met a worse class of people
than apartment complex people oh forget
it it's rough and if I know good people
who moved into apartment complexes but
very quickly on a Saturday night their
house there was people from the
apartment complex over who are
undesirable sure sure once you once you
cross that line you start hanging out
with the neighbors you're jammed up oh
it's Billy from [__] 4B then you're a
weekend away from having a party at the
community pool and then you're in then
there's no way out there's no looking
back yeah there's no looking back I go
in this guy's apartment he's got a couch
a TV on the floor and the rest of his
floor is lined with his bodybuilder
trophies
and he's just that guy you know the tank
top is tied in a knot on the top of each
shoulder yeah like a hot broad
and he's just he's talking nice enough
guy I guess and he goes yeah you're
gonna drive this uh Asian girl
you're gonna pick her up and then you're
gonna go pick her up with my cut when my
cousin gets here like she's the other
girl
uh who's going cousin I was like oh cool
family business hey my cousin's here
walks in it's the girl the first girl
ever no [__]
looks a little worse for the wear yeah
and I was like wow I'm like but okay I'm
like you know I still see her like in
there sort of flowers out from behind
you
three years
I'll find her
I put Miracle Grow on him said he would
stay alive for you just like my love for
you we'll find him
um so she comes out
and uh
I'm like oh you know we kind of like
catch up but she looks she looks a
little rough but I pick her up and this
was the girl I drove her with other
girls before like back those years
before and she was always like the
standout like one she said a great body
sure tan the whole way she just looked
great and young and pretty and we picked
this Asian girl up
the Asian girl
hot did she look like the black widow
yeah when she was young not now Black
Widow turned in exactly what you thought
she was going to turn into a lady
screaming you over fish
[Laughter]
and we go to this thing it's like uh
like a VFW type party
and man these guys so classy classy and
well for the first time I'm seeing him
they don't give a [__] this Asian girl
is working they love her and she looks
great exactly what you're hoping when
she gets a hot young Asian chick
killing it they're laughing almost at
the other one because one of the thing
about her like her skin was like super
tan and just like she looked great
she's super pale and like pasty and
blemishy and then like she's bending
over doing whatever with this Asian girl
they're all all fours together and like
her ass is just kind of like narrower
now and like so you just see her super
like darkened [__] and the people are
standing goes I just hear guys telling
us why is her [__] so dark
[Laughter]
yeah looks like Tommy's ass when he had
that thing I never had that you're
eating meatballs with coleslaw third
ball dude when you can gross out
veterans just guys guys hanging around
staring is piss me a roll definitely
sterno's there a FW Baby the food ain't
bad man I'll tell you that right now
I don't know if you're like a pesto
pasta sure maybe but they uh I remember
the guy's kind of more like laughing at
her more than sure and I was like and
then we go back uh we dropped the Asian
girl off and we go back to that was
where the job I think nothing we never
did any more jobs tonight but part of
that job the thing the job that sucked
was like you'd go if you had one thing
if it was an hour away or 45 minutes
away you'd go to that one thing and that
could just be the only thing or they
could hit you up two times and be like
you're stopping at these two more things
on the way home
and uh so it was like a comeback to my
weird uh
you know weightlifting dungeon and back
to the dojo yeah come back to the dojo
back to HQ
I'm at Dirtbag North HQ
and uh we're sitting there waiting and
we're sitting on his couch and like TV's
on and she starts like for the first
time she's like taking her feet like she
stickers like shoes all the stuff like
digging her feet like under my body and
sort of like up on my thigh and [__] and
I was like not now yeah it's not even
for the thing I'm just like I think
you're gonna give me something now like
that whole room just made fun of your
dookie shoes
you're crazy Brown [__] hey can you
put socks on here you're you're crazy
you're crazy Brown [__]
you don't have to there's more than
[__] you have to bleach there the
discoloration is spread
it's like black mold you gotta take care
of it it's gonna get out there it's like
rust get some tie likes on that yes or
something get some Scrubbing Bubbles do
some lime remover
that's all right
all right you don't find the first time
I've ever even saw cocaine
in my life was when I went back to one
of the this place called Dream Girls in
New York and their headquarters was like
a loft apartment but it was like nicer
thing there was like a desk with a girl
but uh one time and you'd go back there
and wait for things in between that's
where I watched Ellen DeGeneres tell the
world she was a lesbian on The Ellen
Show I saw that Atrium girls HQ at
Dreamgirls HQ but this girl and she was
just like a little like uh like Pudge
like she wasn't she was just a
receptionist she wasn't one of the girls
and then she used she pulled out like a
little bag I've never seen it before and
I was like what's that she goes Coke you
want something I was like no you don't
mind dude I'm like
I don't care but like I did I was like
can we not do drugs I don't know what
it's gonna do to you and it did it was
like a cartoon I'm on the clock right
now a zillion people do Coke at this
point
uh for only have done it doing it twice
myself ever I've seen it a bunch of
times and I've never seen such hit or
like a cartoon
yeah that was people I have friends of
mine who have done Coke a bunch in their
life said the reason they hated the show
vinyl what do you remember that at all
yeah yeah was that the depiction of
doing coke every time he did it it was
just like you go
you know just like start screaming and
having the [__] like an animal right
away and it's like kind of nonsensical
thing she did Coke and was like woo and
stood up and started showing me she
could do handstands I don't think that
was coke and that's Aloft so it's like
I'm glad it's like these kind of piping
and stuff like that she was like doing
Monkey stuff and I was like I was
sitting on the couch I'm like phone's
ringing she'd have to be like you know
doing a Dismount hey
she goes hello
she answers it with her foot yeah
prostitutes are [__] prostitutes or
strippers what do you want press one or
two yeah if you want to [__] the girl
press two if you want to just watch your
strip play Kramer on movie phone ah all
right Jesus Christ all right let's run
through some [__] some ayg questions
here
um have you ever owned a pair of cargo
sweatpants
cargo swept describe them like like
sweatpant material cargo pants that has
the cargo pocket that has the cargo
pocket on the side sweatpants
are strong maybe because that could have
been a pull in the Wu-Tang era sure you
went through some heavy full sweatsuit
faces not too much full sweats I've made
almost everything
I've made almost every mistake you can
make I've seen photos of you at the
laugh house head to toe on the tracks
there's a group there's a great picture
of me with my uh siblings when they were
all really little and I am dressed like
like I went like I was like oh hang on I
gotta take a picture of my family can
you pause this production of the
summertime video by Will Smith like it's
purple and yellow like short set like
that thing so I did those goggles on
your head so I went with I did not ski
goggles for a minute there Wu-Tang era
uh they sold goggles yes that weren't
really for anything no except to be on
the top of your tilted hat yeah they
were not functional you rocked that did
that you're a big accessories guy which
is obviously well documented I do love
accessories for sure but uh okay again
it's funny like most of the
because I do wonder I'm like I'm gonna
hit some sort of a wall where it's just
like well dude it's khaki pants and polo
shirts yeah it's just it's not my
personality at all I think
my personality and clothes never change
necessarily one size is always a factor
in there sure so I think I always kind
of wanted to do more like uh like rock
shirts or things like that when I was
sure I wanted like the Led Zeppelin
shirts but it just
it was going to be tight around my
little tits yeah so it was gonna have to
be uh it was always gonna have to be
like yeah it was gonna have to be like a
South Pole
yeah so I was like being that [__] yeah
okay so probably okay anybody ever uh
anybody in your family ever been on a
local news
no not that I could think of have anyone
in your family ever represented
themselves in court
you know what's funny I shouldn't even
say It's gotta be putting on the side of
the thing my dad's side of the family
his step siblings
are weirdly enough like the uncles on
his side that I know that more than his
actual okay they were just at the Philly
crew those guys and
one of them was mob tied
and the other one his wife was a mob
lawyer
and her dad was like a big guy I think
like in the thing but like
it's Uncle Richie I saw him five times
in my life dude I mean it makes sense I
know what he looks like even but I'm
just like it was never
oh is any of the questions did your uh
mom ever did your mom ever possibly
probably bang one of your father's Step
Brothers yeah no but it can be
let me add that right now yeah Uncle
Tommy
it was uh yeah when I was younger I
thought it was the coolest Uncle Tommy
was a fun drunk of course sure everybody
was drunk back then yeah you're right he
wasn't even that he was just he always
was drinking MGD he just drank it well
back when you were not drinking and
driving
yeah it was like you were just oh I can
go here and drink during the afternoon
because I'm just gonna drive home it
doesn't matter absolutely and uh Uncle
Tom is that but when uncle and his very
fun dude just like a big personality
kind of a loud guy and he uh
in my mind it's always the funniest
thing when you just go it's like yo I
don't know what the reason is I'm not
gonna look to give horse in the mouth
Uncle Tommy's hanging out and that's
pretty cool it's not just me and my mom
watching Falcon Crest with Lorenzo Lamas
I can block the rest of this out no
problem I remember for sure damn okay
they dropped me off together at my
Godmother's house once for a weekend
which I hate I hated staying away from
home when I was a kid I hated it yeah I
was a big fan of it I'd freak out I was
like this I'd cry a lot of it some weird
room
my thing yeah yeah
um and I remember one time
Kicking and Screaming probably not
kicking speed up but whimpering and not
wanting to go the whole time as her and
my uncle Tommy drove me to my grandma's
to drop me off and it's definitely so
they can go back and just plow should
probably sucked him off in the van on
the way back
in the van
[Laughter]
yeah
I had a work fan Uncle Tommy did it
right yeah shout out to us what were
vacations like my dad never came into
town just for my birthday ever once in
my life when my dad heard that Uncle
Tommy was probably banging my mom he
showed up looking for them like to me
yeah he came and found me he didn't live
near me it was a thing for him to come
get me one night he just showed up at my
grandmother's house when I was there and
it's like where's uh where's your mom
it's almost time we've been around a
bunch lately dad are you gonna take me
to a bar I was like is this are we doing
the things like no no no go back inside
you're like if you see him call me yeah
tell your grandmother I'm looking for a
daughter who's empty mgds at ease that's
that's Tommy I know it I mean I'm sure I
I still pigeon my dad on cheating on my
mom for sure
I know that was the beginning of the end
but I mean yeah I probably would have
been like have you seen your mom enough
Tommy and go Uncle Tommy being around is
the best
and by the way from what I hear through
that door it sounds like Mom super happy
yeah she loves him here
what were vacations like as a kid where
would you go
we didn't we no vacations no Cherry Hill
Mall kind of it was just funny but our
tastes were like fine for this so I in
my mind it was never we were going to go
to like the
sure for the weekend or nothing like
that we
again I know what happened was my mom
and steppop did it by themselves first
and they were like well we should bring
to me and my little brother
without me but the vacation was this is
why it's not gonna feel that bad
we were broke so they were like there's
a mall
uh that wasn't that far you weren't no
it's a hotel in by the Baltimore Harbor
yeah yeah it has like a mall attached to
it
um in the Inner Harbor yeah yeah and
they went there before we get and my
when they describe their like
the they're like we just stay in the
room and went to the mall during the day
and then we'd go back in the room and he
answers I can see that's where you like
to go movies on the TV
uh and the room service at this hotel
I'm telling you we were at like a
DoubleTree or something it's nothing
that crazy shot and the room service was
fine but my step you know I was like oh
the burgers the burger and so you got to
see the remote
[Laughter]
you've never seen a remote battles in
this place when they came home they were
like yo we're saving up money and we're
doing that with the kid and we went down
there and did it together in one room
wait till you see
do you see blocks
we stepped out of the indoors of the
hotel slash Mall wants to go get like
crab legs or something like across the
parking lot literally across Joe's Crab
Shack yep yeah yeah it was like some
outdoor place that had like a you know
shelf it's different down here hunt guys
that's so close from the hotel you could
be because he goes That's Camden Yards
right there the Phillies play there
sometimes we don't have tickets
but look at that though look at that
view of Canada
holy [__] man
you are so next level trash it's wild
it's like it's like you came in and
you're like oh you guys playing are you
garbage you guys play Street rules
I did uh you know Justin silver and
Joshua Myers have the himbos podcast
they do now which has like a almost like
what's like your rituals of this on the
same
as I could be so uh in the gutter on the
show with that I I'm also found to be
the most like my
situate like what I do like with
showering you try to keep yourself alive
yeah it's so interesting how it's like
the two things and they are not mutually
exclusive yeah they're somehow both walk
in both worlds you mentioned cologne I
put a little I put a little uh you know
little facial it's called face fuel by
Keels on my face every day there you go
it doesn't seem like I would do that you
do your eyebrows you do the Brows I
certainly wouldn't uh [__] a junkie uh
on her cousin's couch that's the kind of
guy you think I am
straight away to me that was directed at
me I'm offended you know I said when I
got here late today I was like is it
should show up late and you have
Starbucks in a cologne oh yeah and I was
is that in the are you garbage Universe
at all is that like a question that
comes like cologne seems like an
interesting
what do you use it's so I know it I tend
to have good ones yeah I use a Issey
Miyake a lot Christine got me Tom Ford
for Christmas okay and I've had a John
Varvatos black those like the three I
pretty much what were you rocking back
in the day were you a jakar man
my father was a Cologne guy and I
thought when I was his father before him
was a cologne man we'd go down to town
sprinting cologne
laughs
I wouldn't wear You cologne if you gave
it to me as a gift our closets were
lousy with swatches
from the magazine
I've definitely I've definitely rubbed
magazine for sure sometimes you get
lucky I only give you uh
I used to get those for Chris
[Laughter]
Penny oh yeah get a sample get a couple
of shooters
it's like smelling sauce I lived on
those for sure
so my step pop
uh my dad would wear and I always
thought I was like great but in
hindsight on the colognes of what they
were he did a Aspen he did he did Top
Shelf Rite Aid cologne sure yeah uh
you're a big Stetson house Stetson was
all right English leather was a good one
did you ever how about hero or iron yeah
I remember hero iron I don't remember
iron's pretty hilarious
um and although and then as I got older
I was like oh okay it's like the night
is my ex-wife actually she was like if
you like cologne why don't you like good
cologne so you're looking for like I
mean she'd see me like you know in like
a catcher's position in front of a TV a
locked CVS like thing going like but uh
and then in the time this one's 2.99.
again with the uh can I see the Pitbull
like it's a jewelry store
and then I did all of the
whatever came with the idea of a Wu-Tang
pendant and goggles on a hat uh also
came with cool water Nautica sure sure
Tommy sport time yeah the blue the black
oh my God I forgot about that yeah it
was a ck1 ckb man then my
and then my uh this is such a funny
correlation too so my girlfriend at the
time I've ended up getting a job at
Kmart up the block she worked and she
worked in fragrances the jewelry and
sure and perfumes were the same thing so
op Fahrenheit sure I started getting
those like pretty red we were robbing
that place blind the colognes you know
it was all right Obsession remember
Obsession Calvin right Obsession I think
I actually it's a circle yeah my mom got
me that for Christmas like a year ago
that's pretty funny
that's pretty fun she found in an old
closet there you go this was your
grandfather's
I am but that's funny that uh that girl
that
my girlfriend that was Jimmy clone when
we
she broke up me she like dumped me for
another guy
but was in between the thing it was
funny how I caught her doing it was my
um
I was I started doing comedy already so
I was going with uh Kevin Hart and Keith
Robinson we were driving to New York
like all the time so we weren't [__]
legendary we weren't like uh
you know we weren't spending a lot of
time together
and she wasn't even living with me at
this time but uh she had this job or
whatever and she said uh what she was
gonna get me for Christmas that year was
PlayStation 2.
that was a new video game system out and
she said she was looking for it
that's great one night I went to Keith's
me and Kev went to Keith Robinson's
house uh like when we got home that
night and we're just kind of like Alice
played Madden or something it was late
but we're like
let's do it and so I
uh I had my girlfriend when she had a
voicemail
on the pager and I left but then I had
the code for it because we were just
like that's how we would leave messages
she lived with her parents and that's
how we leave messages to each other so I
go hey I'm not gonna be uh able to do
whatever in the late mornings I'm gonna
be sleeping I'm at with Kevin Keith at
campsite whatever it makes something
like hang up and then everyone kind of
quickly goes like I'm actually tired
let's go so then I was like oh I'll just
go delete that message
uh on the thing and I go and says you
have two messages
and one of them was a guy being like yo
I had a really great time and I goes I'd
like to do that again real soon
something like that and I was like oh
and then I had to because when I was
like I was sitting up all night like
waiting until she can answer her phone
in the morning
and then when I called her her thing was
she goes you ask us it's a friend of my
sisters that is true
or if and her brother-in-law's that was
the truth but she goes he's a friend he
goes he's a friend of the family he
works at a place he's the one getting
the Playstation 2 for you for for
Christmas Christmas
ouch should I just go I wanted to
believe that so bad the best I remember
the I'll never forget the faces of Kev
and Keith get in the car because they
were kind of like what's going on I go
I'm an [__] I
you're not gonna believe I started
yelling at her what do you do when
you're cheat you see another guy or
whatever like that and this is the guy
who's getting my Playstation 2 for me
and they like
they laugh at that as they should
what are you [__] they're not doing
the wrong thing yeah they were laying
there man she's [__] them and they're
like yeah for sure they go yeah you
dummy of course they were right but
um did you get the PlayStation though so
this comes back to our thing so uh
the breakup though even the car we were
together for so many years like on and
off like
you know late teens to early 20s
and like she's uh you know she's going
through it too she wants to break up for
sure but like it's also a new world to
her in hindsight I have all this
reflection on it but like and then I'm
like why is she doing because she would
like
say like yeah we're done or whatever I'm
with this guy
and then she would hit me up the next
day and like come over and [__] and be
like I made a mistake I'm gonna be with
you sure and she did one of those and it
was it was awful but the funny
of that story is uh
on Christmas Eve daytime
she calls me with like uh I made a
terrible mistake like we should be
together and I was like but yeah finally
you figured that out okay great like I
mean I'm here waiting like desperately
and upset
and by the way it's so funny months and
months before that was Kevin Keith even
I was like I gotta break up with this
girl like she's it's almost a door now
it's not probably going anywhere it's
just I was like a big oaf and she was
like a cute good body chat and uh you
know I was just used to it and there was
I was gonna bring up but as soon as it
was like she was like yeah I'm gonna
break up with you I was like no please
so I was every time she was like can I
come over I'd be like yes get over here
let's have sex and do all that stuff
again
and so near Dora New Year's Eve
Christmas Eve she calls me because I
made a mistake let's get back there I
want to come over I want to give you
your presents and stuff and see you and
I was like I was like [__]
I thought we were broken up I didn't
even wrap my brain around the idea that
like getting my impressed I was like I
was like this is terrible and I went and
I go it's so funny I mean I had no money
but I spent 70 bucks at like uh in
Deptford Mall on like a ring
that was whatever plated something
bottle of Joop
[Laughter]
I put it you know I have it wrapped and
put in a nice box and like you know and
I'm so like twisted up at whatever you
know 20 years old this is 19. that I'm
almost like I'm gonna tell her it's not
necessarily like an engagement ring but
like it's a problem yeah whatever kind
of thing she comes in
empty-handed by the way
I'm not even a controller it would
appear nothing in her hands
to the naked eye to the naked eye
she goes um
oh so I give her but she cries
uh when I give her the president she's
like oh my God she puts it on she's
doing all that stuff
we're kissing we're hugging and then we
go in the uh other room and she goes
okay
she goes are you ready for your present
now and I was like yeah
yeah I am and uh I close she goes close
your eyes and I'm like whoa and I mean
I'm literally doing like that yeah so
I'm like yo I'm gonna be playing
PlayStation 2 in a couple hours you're
cracking your number there's a lot of
drama going on for sure but this is
gonna lighten the load and all you're
setting up the back of the TV
brand new HDMI cable or whatever oh no
wait that was the uh red that was the
red yellow and white oh yeah RF cables
so
um you know I'm like and she says open
your eyes like I'm like [__] didn't
leave the room
where could this where's this
PlayStation 2 and then uh she has these
three kind of small boxes so funny
I open one it's a
incense and an incense holder yeah I
keep in mind by the way I love incense I
love saying the mood when I play
Playstation 2. I haven't smoked pot in
my life even yet I don't even know what
incense are possibly for do you know
what I mean it's always seemed to me
like you know people like asking me to
buy a purse outside of the Philadelphia
Zoo and incense I don't know I'm like
oh okay okay cool and then she goes open
this the other thing was it was uh
dollar stores version uh it says it on
that's what it's called I mean that
would be like it'll be like Dollar
General version of Tommy oh yeah so she
got me dog she worked at a she worked at
a club thing yeah she got me Dollar
Store one
and then she goes
um I was like oh
thank you and I'm in my mind I'm just
like I guess she didn't get you know it
was a lie anyway he wasn't getting it so
I guess she didn't get it yeah he goes
she goes you ready for your real present
now and I was like oh yeah she goes
close your eyes and now I'm like oh here
we go
[Music]
open them and I'm definitely going like
she would have had to go to the car you
would have heard some rustling of a bag
or something so I hope I was more like
what's this next [__] gonna be
the worst thing I could have even
thought of was she had
at least looking to me I'm not of cash
and she sliced off three 20s and goes I
wasn't able to get the PlayStation so
make sure you get yourself a Playstation
One game get yourself a Playstation One
game like she's an uncle or something
cool hey you're a good kid get over here
keep your money your girlfriend gave you
cash and then like later that day like
her mom and me and her called me like on
like uh you know her mom's on the line
to be like my mom's saying that I was at
your house today because the guy she was
[__] was like a family friend ah and
then parents hated me so they were like
so they were like like will you tell my
mom that I wasn't in your house today
and I'm like she was and we had sex I
was like Cheryl God damn it she looks
like two Chris twenties on me
I got 60 smackers here they gotta chase
back
uh we gotta wrap it up guys Jesus me off
three twenties
did you take them no no I should have
yeah and I said I was taking him yeah I
was like I was like yeah I'll take it
but like get out dumbass
holy [__] man the answer is yes yeah
talk about beating the [__] game look
at it holy [__]
I think I'm home
I mean dude you only got to you're 20
years old
jumped a lot of years in there
that was like the Jesus telling I was
gonna happen what about 13 to 33. oh
don't even get me started there I was
gonna ask if you like Hawaiian pizza
a slice once in a while
like a gentleman once in a while but if
you order it if you get a whole Hawaiian
pizza
there better be a plain or a pepperoni
oh yeah yeah next to it you gotta come
correct you know just you don't offer
someone solely pineapple pizza I got two
Hawaiians on the way [__] yeah I got two
hangers you have you open up one he goes
that's why he goes what's the underneath
another Hawaiian are you pissed
everybody
that's a real decision you want the
Eagles to lose dude what the [__] it's
like making a room smell like your farts
you got something that's funny no yeah
yeah holy [__] ladies and gentlemen the
special dog belly on his YouTube page
right now legendary
love everybody thanks for coming man
what else you want the folks out there
to know other than the special you got
come you got out me and Robert Kelly
doing the bonfire now congratulations
fantastic uh save my ass with a [__]
Legend uh thank God Bobby Kelly's come
on it's been a blast we're doing that
now uh four days a week faction talk
series xm103 of course SDR show and
Legion is skank sure on the gas station
I forgot about the answer show like a
[__] idiot of course you always makes
you guys uncomfortable there a few times
naked girl doing something oh man okay
Gene was beautiful
oh man uh we're all over the road grab
tickets shows are selling out we're
adding some cities but get them before
they're gone we love you gang we love
you to death and we'll see you next week
peace